you've probably found yourself watching
a tournament stream admiring the homies
as they toss out fist bumps in between
rounds taking a quick look at their
desks and wondered quite understandably
why are their keyboards so
freaking
tilt it the crazy thing is that it
almost doesn't matter what shooter
you're watching csgo valorant siege
overwatch hell even fortnite virtually
every aimer worth their salt can be
spotted rotating their keyboard to
various degrees of insanity so like i
can play like this crouching you see i'm
still aligned how do people play like
this this feels so bad the question
again
is
why
from maximizing space to improving focus
to gaining access to additional keys
competitors have spent well over a
decade experimenting with and touting
the benefits of tilting what started as
a result of necessity has since become
the standard for fps's sickest sweatiest
savants but does angling your elbow
really make you better or is it just
some silly outdated posture that edgy
e-gamers adopt for show
also
is it kind of like
really bad for you
[Applause]
okay so before we start cranking our
elbows into some truly cursed
configurations
do me a favor and one tap that thumbs up
spray transfer your way on over to the
subscribe button and finish things off
by usping those notifications on
was that lame i felt really lame like
super lame alright
look
i know i talk a lot of smack about
league of legends players
but if that is honestly the only esport
you watch there's a very decent chance
that this is the first you've ever heard
of players tilting their keebs at weird
inclines how steep are said inclines
well it depends some are slight
some
are
this
so how did it start well it's hard to
say for certain since keyboard tilting
seems to be one of those things that's
just
as old as fps itself you see back in the
day we boomers weren't equipped with
adjustable rgbifi desks the size of
workbenches and desk mats the size of
those who use them no what we had were
dingy decrepit school tables that our
parents made us repurpose from the
nearest curb and they made us carry that
[ __ ] home too
uphill
both ways
in a snowstorm
while doing our chores the worst that
you had to deal with was mommy limiting
your screen time so you couldn't play
minecraft on the ipad before attending
the fortnite concert
zoomers dimitri might be an elitist
boomer but
for once i have to agree with them
anyway gross exaggerations aside most of
esports greatest groundbreakers did
actually cut their teeth on some
scuffed-ass setups look at stewie for
instance dude literally spent his high
school years hitting off flicks in a
freaking drawer or north american dota
divinity fear whose rickety ti-1 era
ensemble has become not only a meme but
a measure of how hard he had to hustle
to make his career work so i didn't have
a monitor so i went to my friend and he
had a spare crt monitor so i got that
and then obviously i have two books here
to punch that up so i can actually see
the monitor so it's kind of a ghetto
setup what such setups engendered of
course
is a profound lack of space
and when your esport of choice is a
tactical shooter
that can be a massive problem why
sensitivity unlike mobas rts's and arena
shooters tax shooters are pretty much
the one esport in which lower
sensitivities tend to dominate the first
of such shooters was of course
counter-strike a quiet unforgiving slug
fest in which every movement every shot
mattered
there were of course maniacs like hiko
whose solution to the small desk and or
pad dilemma was to run an absurdly high
sensitivity turkish operoxic took this
to an extreme solving his admittedly
awful space issues by fragging out at an
unthinkable
2400 edpi it's quick versus open precise
as always
[Music]
jumps into the jaws and what he's so
damn hungry here
he's had his dinner
it doesn't matter where they come from
derek couldn't do a thing and walkstick
is a beast but for the overwhelming
majority of competitors foregoing a
stable consistent reasonable sensitivity
wasn't an option unfortunately
this presented a real issue since back
in the day tournament setups were way
way worse than they are today players
were stuffed like sardines onto stages
that looked like they've been the
stomping grounds of a microsoft reveal
panel circa 1995.
ask any player who's really been around
and they'll tell you some bone chilling
stories about the conditions in which
they've competed so in an effort to make
the most out of the meager miserable
space they were afforded
they did the stupidest silliest most
effective thing they could think of
tilt that [ __ ] and now the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
presented by amd
hold on this is a segment
and somebody bought it
you're telling me that amd wanted to
sponsor me making fun of dimitri
like
the amd the semiconductor company like
radeon graphics and my favorite
processors amd
as a tech guy
that's something i can get behind while
esports as a whole is still relatively
new desk manufacturers catering to
esports is an even newer development in
the late 90s and early 2000s it was
difficult to find a desk purpose built
for a modern home computer let alone one
that had competitive gaming in mind but
that isn't the case anymore we've seen
innovations from large adjustable height
desks monitor arms that flex in every
direction and shares with more
engineering than a space shuttle young
gamers today are free to adopt nearly
any sitting position and specifically
keyboard positioning that feels
comfortable to them which means all the
more reason to give it some thought how
you position your keyboard has some
pretty far-reaching effects on your
muscles joints and tendons from your
fingers all the way up to your shoulders
neck and back but i'm getting ahead of
myself we have an actual ergonomics
expert who's going to be able to explain
this way better than i can and with
physical therapists and ergonomics
experts finding homes at some of the
biggest esports orgs we're likely going
to continue to see the refinement of
setting positions and keyboard tilt huh
wouldn't it be nice not to have to worry
about the inordinate amount of space
your esports players take up with their
gaudy indulgent peripheral setups
oh wait
that's just console esports imagine only
needing desk space for a monitor console
and some sort of audio hardware while
even i can't argue that the controller
is a superior aiming peripheral when
pitted against a mouse and keyboard when
it comes to esports tournament setups
especially open tournaments with dozens
or even hundreds of teams everyone in a
console event is essentially competing
with the same amount of body positioning
freedom they enjoy at home i'm glad amd
recognized where the real brains of this
show is
but please dimitri feel free to get into
the specific ways that mouse and
keyboard players have struggled against
the very peripherals they worship only
to get first rounded at a local land
because they don't have 10 feet of desk
space now keep in mind this was eons
before small concise 60 or 75 boards
became a thing these poor bastards were
run in full sizes which meant that
depending on how hard on the paint they
went they could actually be freeing up a
ton of space which leads us to our sort
of central guiding question
how many kinds of tilt are there
and how much is too much needless to say
there are literally hundreds of angles
at which your switchboard can be slanted
including negative ones so let's narrow
it down to the most popular for starters
you've got your classic run-of-the-mill
straight edge catch your keep loading
into the knife round baby because it has
got zero tilt
this is the style that i use since a i
play dota for a decade and b i like how
it keeps my pinky situated naturally
beneath my ring finger next you've got
your slight 5 degree tilt this i would
venture is the most widespread angle
you'll ever see in fps enthusiast adopt
it gives your thumb easier access to the
c and v keys while also allowing your
pinky to press control without
stretching that [ __ ] out now here's
where things get sweatier we'll call
this one the 45 since it's situated
roughly halfway between 0 and 90 degrees
fingerwise the benefits are pretty much
the same as the 5 degree plus you get
the added desk space we talked about
earlier of course if you want to be a
true e-gamer you're going to have to
throw a post-plant 5 v2 and go on a
near-full 90 degree tilt painful and
awkward as it may appear
there are actually plenty of
accomplished aimers who've made it their
trademark from shaiko to tariq to tifu
do you run out of mouth space on land
games yes
i do
so like i can play like this
and i have this much [ __ ] room
[Music]
like this dude
it's just like
sorry i just out of respect i want to
make sure that our boy colton is keeping
up with all this keeb talk
you nodding off their champ you want us
to run a video with some cod bros
screaming at each other to waken you up
a little bit
go ahead dimitri
so what are the upsides to adopting such
a radical posture well and it's gonna
sound like i'm joking but i'm not it
puts you in the zone tilting your
keyboard to that degree forces you to
hoist your entire elbow on your desk
which as you'll hear fps coach ron rambo
kim talk about in a second
weirdly allows you to really focus up
and with the forward lean you get the
mindset of being more into the game or
more immersed if that makes sense when i
experimented with the forward lean
position i did feel like i can
concentrate a little bit more on the
screen in the crosshair compared to when
i'm leaned back but wait dimitri are
there downsides
yeah no [ __ ] there are it turns out that
holding your keyboard like your gollum
hoarding the precious can crank your
[ __ ] up pretty bad here to walk us
through said crankery is ergonomics
extraordinaire garrick forman a phd
candidate at brock university who
specializes in biomechanics as they
relate to esports tilting your keyboard
or even without the tilt and keyboard a
lot of fps players are always leaning
forward towards the screen they want the
screen to be very close so as soon as
you start to lean
into it you know your spine now is
flexed which means that a lot of the
muscle the musculature around your spine
has to be more active to make sure that
you're
to make sure you're not falling down
basically now i know you're all 18 year
old sheesh spamming pipsqueaks who are
gonna mentally check out as soon as i
utter the word ergo
since
well y'all think you're gonna live
forever
but trust me when i say that ergonomics
is not just boomer [ __ ]
it matters to all gamers
a lot and from what garrick told me the
sort of traditional hunchback make out
with your monitor type stature that a
lot of fps aficionados have adopted over
the years can not only have an adverse
effect on your health but your
performance
so if you are leaning forward typically
your neck has to be flexed back or
extended um you're not going to have to
be extended up to make sure you're you
know you're keeping straight on and so
what people have found from fatigue or
pain in the neck is there's a drop in
proprioception and what that means is
it's the ability the body's ability to
tell where it is in space if you have
neck pain
your ability to tell where your hand is
without looking at it goes down so that
can lead to incorrect key presses um a
slightly slower reaction time it all can
lead i think if you're not careful it
can lead to a lot of detrimental effects
to performance now that's not to say
that bending your board is always a bad
thing for starters it really can give
you access to some crazy configurations
orienting your board vertically grants
you access to keys that you just
wouldn't be able to reach otherwise i
use x with my thumb f with my thumb c
v
b and m all that with my thumb it's just
better because if i was on horizontal
keyboard like i wouldn't be able i would
i would have to reach a lot further to
use that but more importantly it can do
wonders for your wrist if you really
look at your wrist if you're unless you
position very specifically to make your
wrist straight your wrist is going to be
deviated a little bit towards your ulna
which is the
um the bone beside your pinky
um and in ergonomics
our goal pretty much always is to keep
things neutral so it makes sense yes
that there will be that a slight tilt to
it puts your wrist at a more in a more
neutral spot it also i think is a bit
more relaxed too because
the way your elbows come out especially
if you're sitting with arm rests your
elbows are naturally out a bit which
means that
if you're coming in straight to a mouth
or a keyboard like this your wrist has
to be pointed out but if you tilt a
little bit it's much more it's just
creates a straight line from your elbow
down to your fingertips so that makes a
lot of sense that that would be a
benefit it i do find it a little bit
more comfortable too i do find myself
putting into a bit of a slant so all in
all keyboard tilt isn't necessarily a
bad thing as with most things in life a
little can go a long way and contrary to
what i went into this project thinking a
super steep incline can actually up your
game as long as you orient your back and
neck accordingly so start experimenting
see what works for you just be cognizant
of not only how you're gripping but how
you're sitting since that stuff really
matters i've said it before i'll say it
again
getting good is hard
but it shouldn't cause you actual
physical pain
stay safe out there
now i know you're all sheesh spamming
18 year old hey
now i know you're my glasses
can you please put this in your
interjection so i'm not the only one who
everyone thinks is an elitist please can
you put this that's [ __ ] great